so excited to finally see this movie you
guys are gonna love it it's one of my
favorite movies I'm gonna go to the
bathroom real quick don't pause it for
me or anything
[Music]
not only it's today grandma its birthday
it's also an opportunity to honor the
many achievements of this very special
member of the family
and now the Jensen family lifetime
achievement award goes to grandma
[Music]
yes it's like this age infusion kind of
deal Emily wow what a night
you look amazing who are you wearing
got it as a store down the street
Joel you feeling nervous about tonight I
mean there's a lot of competition for
her affection how you feeling about your
chances you know honestly it's an honor
to be on a date with her
yes Queen here we are
whoo maybe this is the color my
daughter's gonna be late fool
I have tallied our scores from our movie
trivia game and the winner is Dave
oh my god I won oh my gosh thank you man
this is heavier than I thought it would
be is always the case right first let's
think best for having everyone over Joel
I want to thank you for seemingly having
seen no movies ever because how many did
you get wrong it's just good to finally
see everything you've worked for come to
fruition you know what I mean well you
don't cuz obviously you did not win this
oh man Oh sounds like I'm getting played
up thank you nice speech buddy but I'm
pretty sure I want that last round I
know who want Best Actress
show me Best Actress oh I can't wait to
work